[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمو وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى
هذه الصور المباشره نتابعها من كياب مع
حديث القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه عن اسقاط
عشر مسيرات في هجوم روسيا على جنوب شرقي
البلاد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
شهر رابع من المواجهات في السودان
معاركم محتدمه في اندرمان والجيش يتحدث عن
عمليه النوعيه ناجحه ووزاره الصحه تتهم
الدعم السريع بقصف مستشفى في المدينه اوقع
قتلى ومع اعلان مصدر حكومي عوده وفد الجيش
الى جده الاستئناف المفاوضات عضو مجلس
السياده شمس الدين الكباشي يؤكد للجزيره
الانفتاح على اي حل يحفظ السياده الوطنيه
قائد الجيش الاوكراني يشدد على ضروره قتال
القوات الروسيه على اراضيها وباستخدام
اسلحه اوكرانيه
ومسؤولون غربيون يقولون ان القوات
الاوكرانيه خسرت 20% من اسلحتها في بدايه
الهجوم المضاد وانها غيرت تكتيكاتها
وموسكو تعلن اكتمال ارسال نحو 150 الف
مجند جديد الى القوات المسلحه
توتر متزايد في شرق اسيا مسؤولون امريكيون
يكشفون عن خطه يعمل عليها الجيشان
الامريكي والياباني منذ اكثر من عام
للدفاع عن تايوان ضد اي هجوم صيني وبجين
تعلن عزمها على اجراء مناورات عسكريه مع
روسيا في بحر اليابان للحفاظ على امن
الممرات البحريه الاستراتيجيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التحذيرات من موجه حر هي
الاشد على الاطلاق خلال الايام المقبله مع
تسجيلي درجات حراره قياسيه في جميع انحاء
العالم من الصين الى اوروبا والولايات
المتحده الامر الذي دفع السلطات التي خذي
تدابير جذريه للتعامل مع القيد والحرائق
التي تعزى الى الاحتباس الحراري وتغير
المناخ لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف
ينعكس التطرف المتزايد للطقس على جهود
مواجهه الاحتباس الحراري
عشرون في المئه قالوا ان ذلك سيسرع الجهود
الدوليه بينما راى 80% انه لن يشكل فارقا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع تسجيل درجات حراره قياسيه في الصين
واوروبا والولايات المتحده تحذيرات من
تداعيات وخسائر ودعوه الى معالجات جاده
لمسببات الاحتباس الحراري
[موسيقى]
يدخل الصراع في السودان شهره الرابع على
وقع مواجهات محتدمه في جبهات عده فقد افاد
مراسل الجزيره باندلاع اشتباكات في احياء
جنوب ام درمان واشار مراسلنا الى تحليق
مكثف لطائرات الحربيه التابعه للجيش
بالتزامن مع سماع اصوات اسلحه المضادات
الارضيه وسط الخرطوم وجنوب ام درمان
وقالت القوات المسلحه السودانيه ان قوه
العمل الخاص التابعه لها نفذت عمليه نوعيه
ناجحه في مدينه ام درمان ونشر الجيش عبر
صفحته على فيسبوك مقاطع مصوره تظهر قوته
والياته العسكريه تتجول في شوارع احياء
المهندسين والعوده
وحمد النيل جنوبي اندرمان
وقالت وزاره الصحه السودانيه في بيان انه
سيارات تابعه لما سمتها ميليشيات الدعم
السريع المتمرده قصفت قسم الطوارئ في
مستشفى سلاح الطبي بامدرمان واتهم الجيش
السوداني قوه الدعم السريع باستهداف مجمع
الطوارئ في مستشفى سلاح الطبي في ام درمان
بطائره مسيره مشيرا الى ان الهجوم اسفر عن
مقتل خمسه اشخاص واصابه 22
معظمهم من المدنيين
وفي ولايه جنوب كردفان غربيه السودان قلت
مصادر محليه ان الحركه الشعبيه شمال جناح
عبد العزيز الحلو قصافت بالمدفعيه الثقيله
احياء سكنيه في مناطق عده بمدينه
كادوقلي عاصمه الولايه ووفقا للمصادر
ذاتها فان القصف المدفعي تزامن مع استمرار
الاشتباكات العنيفه في منطقه حاميه بلنجه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الحركه الشعبيه
كما توغلت تلك القوات داخل الاحياء
الجنوبيه لمدينه الدلنج ثاني اكبر مدن
ولايه جنوب كردفان في وقت تقدمت فيه قوه
الدعم السريع الى داخل الاحياء الشمالي
وفي التطورات بدرفور قالت قوات الدعم
السريع انها تنفي ما سمتها المزاعم
الوارده في تقريره يوم بشان احداث منطقه
مصر بولايه غرب دارفور واضافت انها مستعده
للتعاون مع اي لجنه تحقيق عادله من جهات
محايده تشكل لهذا الغرض وقالت قوه الدعم
السريع انما حدث في ولايه غرب دارفور صراع
قبلي بحث وانها لم تكن طرفا فيه وكانت
منظمه هيومر قد اتهمت قوه الدعم السريع
والميليشيا المتحالفه معها بتصفيه 28 شخصا
من قبيله المساليد وقتل وجرح عشرات
المدنيين في دارفور وقالت المنظمه ان
العديد من هذه الانتهاكات المرتكبه في
سياق النزاع المسلح في السودان التي وقعت
في 28 من مايوير الماضي في ولايه غرب
دارفور وترقى الى جرائم حرب
سياسيا قال مصدر حكومي سوداني للجزيره ان
وفد الجيش عاد الى جده الاستئناف
المفاوضات مع قوات الدعم السريع كان الجيش
السوداني قد علق مشاركته في المفاوضات
اواخر شهر مايوير الماضي احتجاجا على ما
اعتبره خرقا من قوات الدعم السريع للهدنه
من جانب اخر خلع عضو مجلس السياده
السودانيه شمس الدين كباشه ان تامر على
البلاد كبير وان القوات المسلحه تقوم
بواجبها الدستوري واضاف كباشي في تصريحات
للجزيره ان المجلس منفتح على اي مبادره
جاده لوقف الحرب في اطار المحافظه على
سياده الوطنيه ومؤسسات الدوله
واشار كباشي الى ان المبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه متقدمه وان موقف المجلس المبدئي
يدعم الحوار السياسي الموسع والشامل مؤكدا
ان الحوار الشامل يجب ان يفضي الى تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه تقود المرحله الانتقاليه
وتهيئ الانتخابات حره ونزيهه
وقال كباشئ السودان يحتاج الى جهود وطنيه
ومسانده خارجيه
لاعمار ما دمته الحرب
وفي خبر عاجل وخلال اتصال رئيسه مجلس
السياده السودانيه مع الرئيس الكيني رفض
رئيس مجلس السياده مخرجات قمه اللجنه
الرباعيه
للايجاد اذا رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
يرفض في اتصال هاتفي مخرجات ما ورد في قمه
الايجاد وقال انه لا يمكن ادخال قوات شرق
افريقيا دون موافقه حكومه السودان معنى
هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
دكتور انطلاقا من هذا الموقف ليس جديدا
لكنه تاكيد من رئيس مجلس السياده على رفض
ادخال القوات
افريقيه الى السودان
هل الامر جدي الى الى هذا المستوى وهل
بالامكان اساسا ادخال قوات من دون موافقه
الحكومه السودانيه
التحيه لك وللمشاهديك بكل تاكيد لم يكن
واردا ان يتم ادخال القوات
للسودان من دون موافقه الحكومه السودانيه
كما ان مبادره الايجاد نفسها لم تتخذ
قرارات في
الاخير بل اتى
بيان صدر بيان فيه مجموعه من الاشارات
تحويل حظا على الحوار وعلى وقف اطلاق
النار وعلى احترام حقوق المدنيين والكف
عنهم اتى تلويح
باستخدام هذه القوه في متن ذلك البيان
ولكن المبادره نفسها توقفت بعد ذلك بسبب
رفض الحكومه السودانيه لها وامتناع وفد
الجيش السوداني عن المشاركه فيها
يعني الامر يعتبر منتهيا حاليا مبادره في
معلقه تقريبا وبعد ذلك دخلت على الخط
المبادره المصريه التي دعت الحقوق المصريه
دعت الى عقد
لجوار جوار السودان شاركت فيها سبعه دول
هي كل الدول المحيطه والسودان متاثره بهذا
النزاع وقررت ان تشكل اليه وزاريه لمتابعه
الازمه ومحارضيه حلها من قمه لايجاد الى
قمه دول جوار السودان من جديد الى جده
الان يعني الجيش السوداني اعاد وفته الى
جده الاستئناف المفاوضات مع الدعم السريع
وتزعم على ذلك مع تصريحات اطلقها الفريق
اول
سبسب
قائد الجيش السوداني واعلن فيها ان الجيش
منفتح على الحوار وعلى عمليه سياسيه لا
تستثني احدا وتق الى تشكيل حكومه مدنيه
مدنيه وتجهز للانتقابات يعني الجديد الان
الان
سنسال عن الجديد في ذلك لكن الان
المشاورات مشاورات جدا هذه المره هل ستكون
اوسع من نطاق البحث عن هدى
ووقف لاطلاق النار هل ستشمل قضايا سياسيه
هو الامر الذي كان يرفضه الجيش سابقا ذلك
هو الجديد ان الجيش تحدث السابقا في ان
[موسيقى]
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه لن تتطرق لاي
قضايا سياسيه ولن تتطرق لتفاصيل عسكريه بل
ستتحدث او تناقش تفاصيل العمليه الانسانيه
والهدن التي تسهل حياه الناس للمره الاولى
يتحدث الجيش عن عمليه سياسيه من دون ان
يوضح تفاصيل تلك العمليه ومن دون ان يوضح
الاليه التي يمكن ان يتم بها تنفيذ تلك
العمليه السياسيه هؤلاء حتى اطرافه من هم
وبالتالي هناك تساؤلات كبيره في الشارع
السوداني عن هذه القفزه المفاجئه كيف تمت
معلوم ان كل التفاهمات التي تمت في اتفاق
جده او من قبله في اعلان جده لم يتم
الالتزام بها
بواسطه متمرديه الدعم السريع ولكن كانت
كلها يعني فقط حول نقاط وقت اطلاق النار
ادخال المساعدات
واخراج المدنيين وغير ذلك ولم يكن هناك اي
قضيه سياسيه الان
هل يبدو من المشاورات في جده والتي توجه
وفد الجيش الى هناك هل يبدو منها انها
تمهد لتسويه سياسيه هذه المره مع الدعم
السريع بكل صراحه يعني تنازل
الجيش عن رفضه
للتفاوض مع متمردين
اريد ان الدعم السريع ليس له مستقبل سياسي
في السودان شعب السوداني لن يقبل لاي دور
سياسي للدعم السريع في الفتره المقبله بعد
كل ما فعله بالمدنيين من انتهاكات مريعه
من قتل وترويع واغتصاب وخطف ويعني كل
موثوقات الدنيا ارتكب مقاتله الدعم سريع
الشعب السوداني وبالتالي فان الحديث عن
اشراك الدعم السريع في اي حكومه مقبله او
في اي عمليه سياسيه مقبله سيصطدم بالجدار
قوي من الرفض الشعبي في السودان الان
الحديث ينبغي ان ينصرف الى كيفيه ايقاف
الحرب والى اقناع متمرديه الدعم السريع
بان يتوقفوا عن المغامره الحمقاء التي
دخلوا فيها وكلفوا فيها البلاد
والعباد خسائر فادحه واضعوا بها امنها
وطمانيتها دكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكذب
والمحلله السياسي السوداني شكرا جزيلا
اذا اربعه اشهر من المعارك ادت الى وضع
انساني صعب في السودان تحذر المنظمات
الدوليه من تدهوره اكثر اذا لم يتم التوصل
الى صيغه للحل تنهي المعارك وامام استفحال
الوضع لم تعود المساعدات الدوليه كافيه
للتعامل مع حاجيات ملايين السودانيين داخل
البلاد وفي دول الجوار هذا التقرير يقربنا
من الوضع الانساني في السودان حاليا
تستمر المعارك وباستمرارها يتضاعف القتل
والدمار حسب مشروع تحديد وتجميع معلومات
النزاعات المسلحه قتل اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
سوداني وجرح اضعاف ذلك منذ بدء النزاع في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي لا تقتصر مقاس
السودانيين على القتل والجرح فنحو مليونين
واربعمائه الف منهم هربوا من بيوتهم
ونزحوا الى مناطق اكثر امنا داخل السودان
ونحو 740 الفا اضطروا الى الهجره واللجوء
خارج البلاد وعبر الحدود الى دول الجوار
التي تعاني اغلبها من ظروف صعبه لا تسمح
بمنحهم الرعايه الكافيه استقبلت مصر اكثر
من 250 الف لاجئ من السودان واستقبل تشاد
نحو 240 الف وجنوب السودان 160 الفا
واستقبلت اثيوبيا وافريقيا الوسطى وليبيا
اعدادا اقل اربكت المعارك الدوره
الاقتصاديه في البلاد فاصبح نحو نصف
السكان اي نحو 25 مليون سوداني
بحاجه الى مساعده ما ونحو 40% من السكان
في حاجه لمساعدات غذائيه يعد نظام صحي من
اكثر القطاعات تضررا من المواجهات
العسكريه التي عطلت نحو 80% من المستشفيات
مع ما يتبع ذلك من توقف للخدمات الطبيه في
وقت تتحدث فيه منظمات دوليه عن ظهور
الحالات الحصبه والكره بعض السودانيين
وغير السودانيين وجدوا انفسهم اسرى نزاع
لا دخل لهم فيه اذ نقلت رويترز عن منظمه
حقوقيه ان قوات الدعم السريع تحتجز نحو
ثلاثه الاف500 مدني في الخرطوم في ظروف
مزريه
[موسيقى]
هذا ويواصل مواطنون سودانيون النزوح من
مناطقهم بولايه غرب دارفور الى منطقه ادري
في دوله تشاد المجاوره ويعزل اللاجئون سبب
فرارهم الى ارتكاب مسلحين انتهاكات واسعه
شملت قتلى وتعذيب المدنيين مراسل الجزيره
في قدره رصد شهدت بعض الفر
شه رفعت الجثث في خلال ثلاثه ايام نرفع
جسر في الشوارع
في بيوت وحتى الجوامع تعديل الجامع بتاع
المدارس
جنب الزلط برضو يتواجد اكثر من ثمن
الاوامر كان من ميليشيات تحديد هو
اجبرنا انه نمشي
لما نمشي كانت حتى
السفر ولا المجموع رفعت 300
من مدينه الجنينه على الاقدام
مريت في
المشدده
بطريقي انا شاهدته عدد من القتلى متجدعين
في الشوارع
في المحلات
طلقه خمسه في محلات تلجا مجموعه ناس كانوا
يقوم جايين بالليل هرب من الاشياء الحاصل
في الجنينه ويهو تعرض
وبعدين
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا في اول تصريح رسمي من نوعه
قال القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال فاليريزا لوجني انه من
الممكن قتال القوات الروسيه على اراضيها
باستخدام الاسلحه الاوكرانيه بقدر ما هو
ضروري حسب تعبيره واشارز الوجني خلال حديث
لصحيفه الواشنطنبوست الى ان الامر متروك
لتقدير قوته في كيفيه مواجهه القوات
الروسيه واضاف قائد الجيش الاوكراني ان
شركاء بلاده يخشون استخدام اسلحتهم لتوجيه
ضربات اوكرانيه داخل روسيا يشار الى ان
كييف لا تعترف رسميا بانها تنافذ عمليات
عسكريه داخل الاراضي الروسيه
في الاثناء نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن
مسؤولين ان اوكرانيا خسرت ما يصل الى 20%
من اسلحتها في الاسبوعين الاولين من
هجومها المضاد وقال المسؤولون للصحيفه ان
خسائر الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد تراجعت
بدايه من الاسبوع الثالث بعد تباطؤ
الهجمات الاوكرانيه واضافوا ان اوكرانيا
ركزت على اضعاف القوات الروسيه بالمدفعيه
والصواريخ بعيده المدى وانها غيرت
تكتيكاتها
وفي روسيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع استدعاء
147000 مجند للخدمه العسكريه في الجيش بعد
اكتمال عمليات التجنيد في ربيع العام
الجاري يذكر ان مرسومه تجنيد العسكريه
الالزامي صدر نهايه مارس اذار الماضي اما
ارسال المجندين فبدا في العشرين من ابريل
نيسان واكتمل اليوم
معنى من موسكو
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ومن
والاستراتيجي ومن بيرمنج
المحلل الامني والعسكري وعضو المخابرات
البريطانيه السابق
نبدا معك سيد فيليب
الموقف الذي عبر عنه
رئيس الاركان
الاوكراني استخدام السلاح الاوكراني في
ضربات داخل الاراضي الروسيه الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يحظى بقبول غربي هذا الامر
اعتقد ان رئيس الاركان الاوكرانيت حدث
بهذا الامر لان روسيا تهاجم عاصمه
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وشاهدنا في العولى الاخيره مجموعه من
الهجمات من قبل اوكرانيا ضد روسيا والان
القوات الاوكرانيه لا تستخدم الاسلحه
الغربيه في مهاجمه الداخل الروسي لكن اذا
ما ارادت الان اوكرانيا مهاجمه مدن في
روسيا فهذا شيء مبرر لانها تقول بان روسيا
تقوم بشيء مماثل
الاوكرانيون الان لديهم المزيد من القدرات
العسكريه ومن الواضح انهم يستخدمون مجموعه
من التكتيكات التي كانت في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
الاوكرانيه الان اذا ما بدات بمهاجمه
روسيا فهذا بالتاكيد سيقود الى مستوى اخر
من المواجهه الان نعرف ان اوكرانيا لم
تستطيع استخدام
القدرات العسكريه الغربيه في مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه نعرف الان بان اوكرانيا
الان
تتلقى المزيد من الاسلحه
المتطوره الغربيه ولكن لا يسمح لهم
باستخدامها داخل الاراضي الروسيه اذا هناك
الكثير من المحاذير بالنسبه لاوكرانيا في
استخدام السلاح الغربي
لمهاجمه روسيا واعتقد ان الحرب الان
الدائره في اوكرانيا وهذا الامر لن يؤثر
كثيرا على روسيا
نحن هنا لا نتحدث عن السلاح الغربي
زلوجني يقول سلاح اوكرانيا وليس سلاح
الغربي كي لا يحرج حلفائه الغربيين الذين
يمدونه بالسلاح
لقد كانت اوكرانيا تهاجم روسيا بالسلاح
الاوكرانيه داخل الاراضي الروسيه وهذا ليس
بشيء جديد هناك بعد الصواريخ التي تم
تعديلها لمهاجمه اهداف على الارض وفي
الاصل كانت مخصصه لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
اعتقد ان لديهم مجموعه من الاسلحه التي
يمكن تعدلها لكن فعاليه هذه الهجمات تبقى
ضئيله لان تلك الاسلحه الاوكرانيه هي
اسلحه قليله الفعاليه وليس هناك اثر كبيره
لهذه الاسلحه داخل الاراضي الروسيه الرب
ربما الاثر يكونون نفسيا اكثر منه عسكريا
سيد فيليب الولايات المتحده الدول
الاوروبيه بريطانيا
هل هل ستقبل عموما يعني انيت دول النيتو
ايضا هل ستقبل بهذا الامر ان تستهدف اراضي
روسيا ولو بسلاح اوكراني
لا اعتقد ان هناك اي مشكله على الناحيه
السياسيه كما سمعنا ايضا من زميلي في
روسيا اوكرانيا
تستهدف الاراضي الروسيه باستخدام اسلحه
اوكرانيا والى ما قامت اوكرانيا باستخدام
هذا النوع من السلاحه او الاعتماد على من
هم داخل روسيا ومنوئين لروسيا فهذا يعود
للاوكرانيين انفسهم ونحن راينا حدث في
بيلوجروده في الاونه الاخيره على الجانب
الروسي والاختراقات المتعدده لعناصر
محسوبه على اوكرانيا ومدعوه داخل روسيا
اذا اعتقد ان روسيا
تفتقر لي انظمه دفاعيه في تلك المناطق
وراينا ايضا الخلافه الاخيره الذي حصل ما
بين
مجموعه التي تقدمت مسافه كبيره داخل روسيا
وكانت تتجه نحو
كيف تفهم خساره
القوات الاوكرانيه 20% من اسلحتها في غضون
اسبوعين من الهجوم المضاد وهذا يعني حجم
كبير من الاسلحه التي تخسرها مقارنه بما
لديها
ليس هذا بالحجم الكبير نحن نعرف ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تعمل على اكثر من جبهه
القوات الاوكرانيه تهجم قوات روسيه
الصفوف
وايضا اوكرانيا تحصل على الكثير من
الاسلحه الغربيه ذات الفعاليه الكبيره
ونحن نعرف ان روسيا خسرت مجموعه من
المعدات الغربيه لكن هذه المعدات سيتم
تعويضها وتزويد اوكرانيا
ببدائل ودخائر للاستمرار في المواجهه
واعتقد ان اوكرانيا اقلمت مع طبيعه
المعركه نعم اوكرانيا او القوات
الاوكرانيه تتقدم ببطء لكنها تحرز اهدافا
حقيقيه وتعمل على فتح جبهات المفاجاه
الاخوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيون يهاج ايضا مراكز اللوجستيه
لامداد الجيش الروسي بالتالي اعتقد ان
اوكرانيا تهاجم بشكل فعال الخطوط الدفاعيه
للقوات الروسيه
يعني خساره 20% من اسلحه القوات
الاوكرانيه في اسبوعين من الهجوم المضاد
حسب ضيفنا السيد فيليب ليس بالامر الكبير
قياسا الى التكتيكات المتبعه والى ما
تحققه على الارض هذا ليس حجما كبيرا ما
رايك في ذلك
[موسيقى]
والقوات المسلحه
الروسيه تسعى وتريد وتطمح لكي تخسر
اوكرانيا المزيد من الاسلحه
والروسيا الان تعمل على وقف الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني واذا مات خسروا كل المخدرات
الدفاعيه وكل
المعدات العسكريه فهذا سيدعم موقف روسيا
بشكل جيد واعتقد ان
الامور ستتغير بحدود الشهر اكتوبر حيث
سيدخل فصل الخليفه ونتج عن فاصل الشتاء
اعتقد ان
روسيا ستنظر الى هذا التحول الى ما استمر
على انه شيء ايجابي وقد نشهد مع بدايه
العام ربما وقف الاخلاق النار
وهذه هي قراءه للمستقبل من جانب الروس
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا فلديهم اهداف اخرى على
اوكرانيا
ان تحاولوا ان تكسب المزيد من الاراضي
واعتقد ان اوكرانيا لديها شهرين متبقيين
لاحراز هذا الهدف لكن لا اعتقد ان
اوكرانيا بامكانها ان تحقق هذا الهدف
لانها تتعثر الان في مواجهه الدفاعات
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من موسكو
وشكرا ايضا
المحلل الامني والعسكري وعضوي المخابرات
البريطانيه السابق من
[موسيقى]
الى توتر في شرق اسيا فعلى وقع خلافات
امريكيه يابانيه متصاعدا مع الصين نقلت
صحيفه
عن مسؤولين قولهم ان الجيشين الامريكي
والياباني يعملان منذ اكثر من عام على خطه
للدفاع عن تايوان في حال وقوع هجوم صيني
ولكن من دون ان يشارك الجيش الياباني
عسكريا في الاثناء اعلنت وزاره دفاع
الصينيه ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه ستشارك
في تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه تنظمها الصين في
بحر اليابان قريبا
[موسيقى]
وكان شرق اسيا قاب قوسين او ادنى من تشابك
استراتيجيات دولها العسكريه
تتشابك كثير من خيوط هذه الاستراتيجيات مع
المصالح الامريكيه والغربيه خاصه في غمره
تحرك روسيا والصين لتعزيز التعاون العسكري
بينهما قالت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه ستشارك قريبا ضمن
تدريبات مشتركه تنظمها بالجيم في بحر
اليابان ضمننا تصفه بخطط التعاون العسكري
بين البلدين هدف التدريبات كما تقول الصين
هو تحسين التفاعل الاستراتيجي بين قوات
البلدين بالتركيز على امن الممرات البحريه
والحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار الاقليميين
والاستجابه المشتركه للتحديات الامنيه
مثل هذا التعاون العسكري وهو ليس الاول
يمثل براي كثيرين ردا عمليا على تصاعد
التحركات العسكريه الامريكيه في بحر
اليابان وهو من النطاقات المهمه
استراتيجيا لكل من بيجين وموسكو
تثير هذه التطورات بالطبع حفيظه الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في المنطقه وخارجها
ولطالما اعتبرت ان الصين تمثل بتحركاتها
تهديدا على ما تسميه نظام المنطقه القائمه
على القواعد ولا تخفي تعزيز استراتيجيات
دفاعيه اوسع في المنطقه ربما لمواجهه
تداعيات ذلك
وليس بعيدا عن هذه التطورات نقلت
عن مسؤولين قولهم ان الجيشين الامريكي
والياباني يعملان منذ اكثر من عام على خطه
للدفاع عن تايوان اذا هاجمتها الصين ولكن
دون ان يشارك فيها الجيش الياباني وقالت
الصحيفه للنوا حدث طوكيو على النظر حينئذ
في دور لجيشها مثل تتبع الغواصات الصينيه
حول تايوان وتشمل الخطه ايضا طرق الامداد
ومواقع اطلاق الصواريخ
الاجلاء وقالت ان اليابان مستعد لتوفير
الوقود وامدادات اخرى للجيش الامريكي لكنه
يرفض اشراك جيشه في اي حرب مع بجين قد
تندلع حول تايوان تتم هذه الخطه ضمن
المرحله الاولى من استراتيجيه الامن
القومي للاعوام الخمسه القادمه والتي
اقرتها الحكومه اليابانيه في ديسمبر
الماضي والتي تشمل خطوط وحدود تعاون
الطوكيو العسكري مع الدول الاخرى وترحب
واشنطن بمثل هذا التعاون الذي يوافق
استراتيجياتها رغم تحفظات الصين وفي
المقابل تمضي بجين ايضا في تنفيذ
استراتيجياتها الامنيه دون اقتراث لتحفظات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
في اخبارنا الاخرى تواصلت للاسبوع الثامن
والعشرين على توالي المظاهرات في اسرائيل
ضد التغييرات في النظام القضائي وطلب الاف
المتظاهرين في تل ابيب بحمايه الديمقراطيه
وحق الاحتجاج والتعبير حسب وصفهم وتاتي
هذه التظاهره بعد ايام فقط من اقرار
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بالقراءه الاولى
قانونا يقلص صلاحيه قضاه المحكمه العليا
في الاثناء اعلن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ان اجتماع الحكومه الذي كان
مقررا غدا تاجل بسبب استمرار وجود
بنيامينه ياهو في المستشفى وظهر نتنياهو
في تسجيل مصور قال فيه انه تعرض للشمس
فتره طويله خلال قضائه وقتا عند بحيره
طبريا وكان ديواننا نتنياهو قد قال ان
رئيس الحكومه داخل المستشفى بعد فقدانه
الوعي في منزله بمدينه قصاريه جنوب حيفا
واضاف الديوان في بيان ان نتنياهو نقل الى
مستشفى في شرق تل ابيب واجريت له سلسله
فحوص
نظم فلسطينيون بينهم ناشطون حقوقيون وقفه
احتجاجيه اليوم في رام الله لتنديد
باستمرار اجهزه الامن الفلسطينيه في
اعتقال طلبه جامعيين والناشط الصحفي عقيل
عواوده وردد المشاركون في الوقفه هتافات
ترفض ما وصفوها بسياسه الاعتقال السياسي
ومنع حريه الراي والتعبير وطلبوا بالافراج
الفوري عن المعتقلين وكان جهاز الامن
الوقائي في رام الله قد اعتقل مساء الخميس
الماضي الصحفي عطيل عواوده بعد نشره مقطع
فيديو عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينتقد
فيه حديثا للناطق باسم الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه نفافيه وجود اعتقالات سياسيه
في الضفه الغربيه
استقبل امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
ال ثاني الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد [__]
الذي وصل الى الدوحه في زياره عمل تستغرق
يومين ومن المقرر ان تبدا غدا المباحثات
الرسميه بين الجانبين القطري والجزائري
والتي تتناول سبل تعزيز العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين والقضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك وهذه الزياره تعد الثالثه التي
يقوم بها الرئيس الجزائري الى العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه منذ تسلمه السلطه
في تطورات الاوضاع في في تونس التي تعيش
على وقع ازمه هجره غير مسبوقه في ظل وجود
اعداد كبيره من المهاجرين المقيمين بشكل
غير قانوني نقلت وكاله رويترز عن مسؤول في
مجلس الامن القومي التونسيه قوله ان
المهاجرين في تونس تلقوا هذا العام
تحويلات من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
بقيمه تناهز مليار دولار في المقابل تنتقد
منظمات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه تعامل سلطات
مع المهاجرين ووصف المنتدى التونسي للحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الوضع الانساني
لطالبي اللجوء الافارقه بالصعب للغايه
وكان الرئيس التونسي قد اتهم خلال اجتماع
مجلس الامن القومي التونسي اتهم دوائر في
الخارج بالتخطيط لعمليات الهجره في بلاده
ارقام رسميه
تم العمل عليها خلال
الايام الماضيه
تتعلق
بالاموال الطائله
التي
وصلت الى تونس
وتمثل دليلا
على ان هؤلاء
الذين يتاجرون
بالبشر
وباعضاء البشر
يستهدفون ايضا الوطن
اعتبر الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي ان اغلاق السلطه
الحاليه باب الحوار قاد البلاد الى ازمات
اجتماعيه واقتصاديه عده مشددا على ان
الاتحاد يمد يده للحوار من اجل تحقيق
الوحده والاستقرار
بلادنا ماهيش في حاجه الى اكثر توترات
بلادنا في حاجه الى استقرار بلادنا في
حاجه الى وحده ولكن الوحده لاي قاعده على
قاعده معناها ثوابت معنا معينه ولكن اليوم
اللي يحب ينفرد بكل شيء ما عليه اللي
يتحمل مسؤوليته احنا مدينه الحوار وليس
هذا اني طلب الحوار انه ضعف لا بالعكس هو
من شيام الكبار وعلامه فارقه ودليل قاطع
على النضج وعلى الوعي
رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني احمد نجيب الشابي
الى تنظيم مظاهره كبرى يوم الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو تموز الجاري للمطالبه
بالعوده الى المسار الديمقراطي واسقاط
الانقلاب حسب قوله وجدد شاب خلال الوقفه
الدوريه لجابات الخلاص مطالبته باخلاء
سبيل كافه المعتقلين السياسيين مؤكدا
ضروره الاستمرار في التحرك الميداني من
اجل العوده للشرعيه والديمقراطيه واسقاط
ما وصفه بالانقلاب
[موسيقى]
تستعد دول في انحاء العالم لمواجهه اعلى
درجات حراره على الاطلاق خلال الاسبوع
المقبل ففي تونس والجزائر والمغرب اقتربت
درجات الحراره من حاجز الخمسين مئويه
وحضرت السلطات في دول اوروبيه من احتمال
تجاوز الحراره اربعين درجه اما في
الولايات المتحده بحسب هيئه الارصاد فان
قرابه خمسه وثمانين مليون امريكي سيكونون
عرضه لموجه الحر الشديده هذا وقد تزايدت
الدعوات الى معالجات جاده لمسببات
الاحتباس الحراري وتغير المناخ
مزيد من الحراره والسخونه وصلت او تكاد
الى مناطق مختلفه من النصف الشمالي
لكوكبنا وستكون ايام الصيف استثنائيه لجهه
درجات الحراره غير المسبوقه
تتسبب ما تعرف بالقبه الحراريه ارتفاع
درجات الحراره القياسيه وهي الظاهره تحدث
في طبقات الجو العليا التي تعرف
استراتسفير حيث تكون درجات الحراره متدنيه
في الوقت الذي تكون فيه درجات الحراره
مرتفعه في طبقات الجو الدنيا المعروفه
الفرق بين هاتين الطبقتين يشكل منطقه ضغط
جوي عال
فعند صعود الهواء الساخن من الاسفل الى
الاعلى تسخنه الشمس ثم تدفعه منطقه الضغط
نحو الاسفل وعندها يصبح مضغوطا واكثر
سخونه
ارتفاع الحراره القياسي سيشمل دولا
اوروبيه وولايات امريكيه ودولا في منطقتنا
كتونس والجزائر وغيرهما
اللافت ان دول اسيويه تشهد فيضانات عارمه
بسبب امطار غزيره في باكستان والصين ودول
اخرى لكن في الواقع ان الفيضانات مرتبطه
بالحراره فقبل ايام ذكرت المنظمه العالميه
للارصاد الجويه التابعه للامم المتحده ان
نمط طقس النينيو والاحتراري قد بدا للتو
وان درجات حراره سطح البحر في العالم وصلت
مستوى قياسيا خلال اشهر
وظاهره النينيو هي ارتفاع صخوله سطح مياه
المحيط الهادي قباله سواحل امريكا
الجنوبيه
تنتشر هذه المياه الدافئه عبر المحيط
دافعه بحراره كبيره نحو الغلاف الجوي
كما تحدث موجات الحر البحريه عصير
استوائيه تترافق مع هطل غزير للامطار على
اليابسه
وفي اقصى جنوبي الكوكب قالت المنظمه
الدوليه انها سجلت انخفاضا قياسيا في جليد
منطقه القطب الجنوبي التي كانت تصنف بانها
مستقره نسبيا بسبب شده برودتها باخلاف
القطب الشمالي الاقل بروده اذا انه المناخ
مره اخرى يفرض تغيره وظواهره الحاده وغير
المسبوقه تحديات امام كل سكان الارض
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بالعوده الى موضوع التدريبات
البحريه بين روسيا والصين نستعرض واياكم
اهم محطات التدريب المشترك بين البلدين في
بحر اليابان من ابرزها تدريبات قادها
اسطول المحيط الهادئ الروسي في يونيو
الماضي بمشاركه اكثر من 60 سفينه حربيه
وسفينه دعم وفي ديسمبر من العام الماضي
بدات الدولتان مناورات عسكريه بحريه
مشتركه بالذخيره الحيه تشمل اطلاقا
للصواريخ على اهداف بحريه وجويه وفي
سبتمبر من العام نفسه انطلقت مناورات
فوستوك 22 في بحر اليابان وشارك فيها اكثر
من نصف مليون جندي وخمسه الاف قطعه عسكريه
منها 140 طائره و60 باخره حربيه وفي
اكتوبر من عام
2021 اجرى البلدان مناورات بحريه شاركت
فيها سفن حربيه وسفن ودعم من اسطول المحيط
الهادئ الروسي بما في ذلك كاسحات الغان
وغواصه
بحر اليابان كما يتم تعريفه دوليا اليوم
ظل محل خلاف حول تسميته على مدى عقود بين
الدول التي تتشارك حدوده المائيه
تعود الخلافات بين اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه حول تسميه البحر الذي يفصل بين
البلدين الى اطلاق الجيش الياباني على ذلك
البحر مسمى بحر اليابان خلال فتره استعمار
اليابان لشبه الجزيره الكوريه
وتم حذف تسميه بحر الشرق كما تسميه كوريا
الجنوبيه خلال المؤتمر الاول للمنظمه
الدوليه للمسح البحري حيث اتخذ المؤتمر
قرارا بانشاء تسميات حدود البحار
والمحيطات
وعبر تاريخ كان بحر اليابان حاجزا طبيعيا
امام الهجمات على الارخبي
للحديث عن هذه المناورات ينضم الينا من
بيجين فيكتور نائب رئيس مركز الصين
والعولمه كما ينضم الينا من ولايه ديلاور
لاريكورب كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي ومساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق وابدا معك سيد فيكتور
هذه المناورات التي تستعد روسيا والصين
لاجراءها في بحر اليابان هل تختلف بمغزاها
العسكري والسياسي ورسائلها عن مناورات
مشتركه سابقه
وروسيا لديهما طبعا حدود تتجاوز 4000
كيلومتر
وهناك علاقات قويه ما بين البلدين خاصه
بعد خروج روسيا من الاتحاد السوفياتي
هناك علاقات قويه ما بين روسيا والصين
وكلاهما هي ودان
قصار جهد ماء من اجل الحفاظ على الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وهناك تعاون وثيق
بين اثرفين من اجل الحفاظ على الامن
والاستق فيه المنتخب بالنسبه لبحر اليابان
فهذا بحر الدول ومره الدولي
والدول المجاوره
لديها
علاقات
وطبعا هي مرتبطه بالاتفاقيات البحريه
الدوليه ونحن نعرف تداعيات الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وهناك حقائق ثابته والكل يريد
المحافظه على الوضع الراهن في المنطقه في
منطقه بحر اليابان
بالنسبه
المناورات العسكريه المشتركه بين الصين
وروسيا فهي لا تستهدف اي بلد هي فقط
مناورات للحفاظ على الامن والاستقرار ولا
ينبغي باي طرف يتفاجا بان روسيا والصين
سيستمر عنا في هذا النوع من التعاون
العسكري في ذلك مناوله عسكريه بريه وبحريه
وايضا جويه
هل تراها الولايات المتحده
مناورات روتينيه
كما يود ضيفنا
منبجيين ان يصفها
طيب اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قلقه بالنظر بالسرديه التي تستخدمها الصين
فيما يتصل
بالاستحواذ على تايوان بالقوه
وبالتاكيد الروس
ينضمون الى الصينيين الى ما قرروا اجتياح
اوكرانيا وبنفس المطاف الوجد مدحت
الامريكيه ستكون داعمه لتايوان بمعنى اخر
ماذا تقصد ان تقول بالنسبه لهذه المناورات
سيد لاري
هذه المناورات العسكريه ليست جديده كما
اشار زميلي من بيجين هذه المنارات
العسكريه لديها تاريخ وشهدناها منذ فتره
طويله
والبلدان يقومون بهذه التدريبات بين
الفينو الاخرى الشيء الجديد هو او هي
السرديه الصين فيما يتعلق
بالاستحواذ على
القوه في وفق
واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واليابان وبقيه الحلفاء يعملان على تقويه
تواجدها في المنطقه الحديث عن هذه السرديه
سرديه الصين بالاستحواذ بالقوه على على
تايوان
الجيشان الامريكي والياباني وضع خطه
للدفاع عن تايوان على ان لا يتدخل الجيش
الياباني
عسكريا سيد جاو
ما رايك بما اعلن عن عن خطه من هذا النوع
للدفاع عن تايوان بين الولايات المتحده
واليابان
الى مجموعه من النقاط في السابق ومنذ عقود
الصين كانت دائما تنهج السياسه الامن
والسلامه اتجاه تايوان ولا حاد في الصين
يتحدث عن تحرير تايوان في وفق 27 هذه
سرديه امريكيه لا يحد لا احد يتحدث عن
الحرب نحن نسعى للسلامه نريد ان
يستتب الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه وهذا
هو املنا وهذا هو طموحنا ولا ينبغي التدخل
في القضايا الداخلي الصين الشيء الثاني
السيده لاريتا حدث حول الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اذا دعوني اقول شيئا للتوضيح
اليابان في 1945
انهزمت في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وفي ذلك الوقت لا يكون اي احد يتحدث عن
القضيه
التايوان على اليابان الان لا ينبغي لها
ان تحمل السلاح ضد الصين نعرف ان اليابان
خسرت الحرب واستسلمت
لن تسمح بالتدخل في الحرب او في اي قضيه
مرتبطه بالسين اي تعرف يسعى لدفع اليابان
في الدخول في حرب مع الصين فسيكون متهما
بالضلوعه في جرائم ضد الانسان هي لذلك لا
ينبغي لاحد ان يضع في حسبنه النشوربه حرب
بين اليابان والصين
ما يتعلق
الامريكيه والصين نحن نذكر مرارا وتكرار
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعترف بان الجزء من الصين وهذا الشيء
مكتوب ولا يمكن لاي احد ان يغير هذا الامر
واذا ما حاول اي احد ان يغير هذا الوضع
الراهن فهذا سيجر الكثير
اتضحت الفكره والسيد لاريكورد طبعا سوف
سوف يرد على العديد من من النقاط
اساسا ليس هناك سيد لاريكورد اي نيه صينيه
للاستحواذ بالقوه على التايوان التي هي
اصلا جزء من الصين كما تعترف الولايات
المتحده بمبدا الصين واحده هذا اولا ما
رايك
الواحد لكن نقول لا يمكن
ان تجعل جزءا منها بالقوه بالتاليه
الصينيون يقومون بمناوره عسكريه تقوم
بخرقه الحد الفاصل ما بين الصين
وايضا
[موسيقى]
الصينيون قاموا بعرقله حركه الملاحه
لمجموعه من السفن
في بدايه القرن كانت الصين قد استهدفت
طائره امريكيه في المنطقه ايضا اعتقد ان
الفكره خلف قضيه قلق اليابان بخصوص
التصرفات السلميه فهذا يعود لعمل الصين في
المنطقه وتحركاتها في المنطقه اعتقد ان
اليابان لها الحق فيه الدفاع ايضا عن
نفسها كما هو الشان بالنسبه لبقيه الدول
الاخرى الان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واليابان لا
تقوم بخطوات عدائيه ضد الصين الان القضيه
هي التزايد عدائيه الصين في المنطقه
وعلاقتها مع
سعيها للاستحواذ شكرا بفوق 2027 شكرا لك
من ولايه ديلاورو وشكرا لضيفنا فيكتور جاو
كان معنا من بيجي
انتهى الحصاد شكرا للمتابعه
[موسيقى]